you have this idea to do Horace and P so
I start writing it and then I'm reading
an article about Edie Falco and I look
at her face in the article and I go
you're gonna be on my show I just know
it you visualize yes and then I go to
the Emmys yes and she's sitting by
herself with a seat next to her
I don't know Edie I mean I ran into a
few times hello I'd sit next to her you
sat your ass down I just saw that chair
and I'm like [ __ ] it and I sat down and
what do you say to her I said to her I
have a show I'm writing Steve Buscemi
and ironing it together because he had
agreed to do it now and I said I want I
want you to play that I wrote a part for
you and then here's the thing I'd also
written a part for Jessica Lange so I
walk away from I tell you going to the
Emmys is the best place to catch
something is already Falco this is my
this is a show like wrote it for you
only you can play this part right and
then I walk away and Jessica Lange
standing right there
so I go up to just glad and I go hey I
have a new show I want you to be in it I
wrote a part for you can really see
DeFalco look at him because she said hey
way to take this guy's mental he's going
up to everyone at the Emmys great he's
over there with Weird Al Yankovic and we
got to hear what I did